من نيويورك معنا مندوب فلسطين لدى الامم
المتحده رياض منصور سيد رياض شكرا جزيلا
لك على تلبيه دعوه العربيه هذا المساء
بدايه هل تلقيتم اي رد على طلب السلطه
الفلسطينيه عقد اجتماع عاجل لمجلس الامن
الدولي لمناقشه وادانت الجرائم
الاسرائيليه في نابلس
اولا شكرا على استضافه لقد التقيت ظهره
هذا اليوم مع رئيسه مجلس الامن سفيره
مالطا ووضعتها بصوره اخر التفاصيل حول
المذبحه والجرائم التي ارتكبت سلطه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ضد اهلنا
الصابرين والصامدين في مدينه نابلس
الباسله حيث ذهب ضحيه هذا العدوان عشره
شهداء 102 من الجرحى جزء منهم وضعهم في
حرج وفي غايه الصعوبه وفي النقاش والتداول
مع رئيسه مجلس الامن وبعد ان اعطيتها
بيانا مذكره لتشارك اعضاء مجلس الامن بها
وكذلك للامين العام ورئيس الجمعيه العامه
اتفقنا على الاستمرار في
المشاورات وسيمتد ذلك عبر المندوب العربي
الامارات العربيه المتحده الذين نشكرهم
على جهودهم وجميع المجموعه العربيه بقياده
الشيخ علياء رئيسه المجموعه العربيه لهذا
الشهر على التواصل مع اعضاء مجلس الامن
بهدف تربيه الطلب الفلسطيني بشان ان يتحمل
مجلس الامن مسؤولياته وان
يقدم على
اعتقد النفقات نعم نعم سيد رياض نعم نحن
نسمعك بشكل واضح ولكن بانتظار ان يصلح
الزملاء ان يوصلوا صوتي اليك نعم تفضل سيد
رياض كنت تحدثت انك وضعت رئيسه مجلس الامن
الدولي في الصوره ما يحدث في نابلس هلا
وضعتنا نحن ايضا والمشاهدين في سوره
ما الذي يحدث في في نابلس لماذا هذا
التصعيد الاسرائيلي
الان برايك وهو ياتي بعد سلسله جهود
للتهدئه زياره بلنكن وحديث عن مشاورات
ربما بين السلطه الفلسطينيه واسرائيل
لتهدئه الاوضاع لماذا هذا التصعيد الان في
في نابلس
يعني جميعنا نعرف على ان هذه الحكومه هي
الحكومه الاكثر تطرفا في تاريخ الحكومات
الاسرائيليه وتحتوي على وزراء في صفوفها
هم
يعني فاشيين ولقد قدموا الى المحاكم
الاسرائيليه
وصنفوا على انهم ارهابيين وكذلك هكذا
تتعاطى معهم الاداره الامريكيه والحكومه
الامريكيه ولذلك لا نستغرب ان مثل هؤلاء
المتطرفين والفاشين يريدوا تفجير الاوضاع
في المنطقه
لانهم يريدوا من ضمن عده مسائل ان يعرفوا
الانظار عن المشاكل الداخليه الكثيره التي
يمر فيها المجتمع الاسرائيلي على ايه حال
لست انا الشخص الذي يعطي تفسيرا لماذا
يقدم على مثل هذه العمليات عليهم ان
يشرحوا لماذا ان يقوموا بذلك لكن يهمنا
على ان الشعب الفلسطيني يتصدى لهذا
العدوان بكل كبرياء
ولن يسمح لسلطه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
والمستوطنين المجرمين الذين يشنوا غضبهم
وعدوانهم على شعبنا بان يكسروا ارادات
الشعب الفلسطيني نحن ندين هذه الاعمال
الاسرائيليه باشد العبارات ونريد لمجلس
الامن ونريد للمجتمع الدولي وللاميد العام
شخصيا ان يتحملوا مسؤولياتهم في تطبيق ما
اقر سواء في مجلس الامن ام عبر تقرير
الامين العام في توفير الحمايه للسكان
المدنيين وسنتواصل مع اعضاء مجلس الامن في
الايام القادمه لان يتحمل المجلس
مسؤولياته وان تعقد جلسه لمجلس الامن
طارئه وفق ما اشرت اليه في تصريح وزير
الخارجيه الدكتور رياض المالكي وهذه
تعليمات التي لدي من قبل القياده
الفلسطينيه واشكر الاشقاء العرب على
وقوفهم معنا في هذا المجال سيد رياض كما
ذكرت يعني
في الاقتحامات السابقه كذلك الاسرائيليه
في نابلس جرى بعدها عمليات انتقاميه ان
كان في القدس وفي مناطق اخرى واليوم
الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه رفعت مستوى
التاهب الامني الى اين تتجه الامور هل
الوضع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه متجه الى
الانفجار
انا انا لا استطيع ان اتكلم عن غضب الشعب
الفلسطيني
وتصديه لهذه الهجمات والعدوان عليه
وبطبيعه الحال عندما يزداد هذا العنف
من قبل سلطه الاحتلال
والارهاب من قبل المستوطنين ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني يصبح من الطبيعي التوقع احيانا
ردود فعل من البعض على هذه الاعمال التي
هي سلطه الاحتلال مسؤوله عنها نحن من
جانبنا يعني سنبقى ندافع عن قضيتنا في كل
المحافل وفي المقدمه منها مجلس الامن ومع
الامين العام والجمعيه العامه لان هذا
واجبنا وهذا المجال الذي نعمل فيه وننفذ
اراده الشعب الفلسطيني ونتفهم غضبه ونتفهم
انه غاضب على ليس فقط سلطه الاحتلال
والمستوطنين وانما كذلك من نواحي مفهومه
على المجتمع الدولي الذي لا ينفذ ولا يطبق
قراراته في مساله توفير الحمايه للسكان
المدنيين الى ان ينتهي الاحتلال ويحظى
الشعب الفلسطيني بانجاز استقلال دولته
وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه اشكركم شكرا جزيلا
على الاجابه عن اسئلتنا الاستاذ رياض
منصور انتم طبعا مندوب فلسطين لدى الامم
المتحده كنت معنا من نيويورك